thank you guys all for coming yeah it is
very weird for me to be here I did come
here as a student and listen to many
famous entrepreneurs come and give
lectures I remember the first one that I
came I had a venture capitalist or I was
like a real estate guy come up to me and
say wolf he gave me his business card
and he said here if you ever need office
space you know call me and I was like
what do you mean anything well you know
you're gonna start a company someday so
when you when you want to just get some
office space so yeah my role in the in
the world now is very different than I
actually thought it would be when I was
at Stanford I was so I graduated here in
2006 as an undergrad in computer science
I took mostly symbolic systems classes I
was very interested in cognition in the
mind and neuroscience and psychology and
I got particularly interested in a lab
here called the persuasive technology
lab does anybody here know the
persuasive technology lab some of you
okay if you didn't know the persuasive
technology lab is basically top i BJ
Fogg he's a psychology professor and he
pioneered this field of persuasive
design how do you persuade people how
does that work and how could technology
persuade us for good that was the
question and this lab was filled with
young engineering students mostly
computer science business psychology
students many of whom went on to join
the ranks of you know Facebook and
actually my project partner in the class
my Krieger was here from Stanford and
found an Instagram actually using a lot
of the techniques that we designed I
learned about and the thing that caught
my attention in that class was this last
semester the very at the very last class
of the semester was about what is
ethical persuasion what does it mean to
be able to ethically and personally
persuade a human being
and we actually talked about this
thought experiment well what if you
could get the perfect profile let's say
every amount of information about how
this particular human beings minds works
and you could use that information to
persuade them towards anything so this
was sort of a thought experiment that we
were running and it turned out that that
question became ten years later the
thing that I now do basically for a
living and I'm concerned about and that
frankly is one of the most important
hidden and invisible topics of our time
right now if you're aware in the last
election including today where the
hearings in Congress with the major
technology companies Facebook Google and
Twitter testified before Congress
specifically about the ways that their
platforms were used to persuade the
American public in the election and and
what Russia what Russia's role was in
that and using these platforms so and if
you didn't know a Cambridge analytic
which is a company that basically the
Trump campaign used but and also for
brexit to basically create a
personalized profile of what would
persuade people so these questions that
I was really interested in became really
the foundation of possibly one of the
most important you know things that's
going on in the world right now so why
does this matter what is ethical
persuasion matter really this is a
conversation about values you know when
you when you're in this class and you're
thinking what does it mean to ethically
persuade people you think well who's to
say what that would be good for someone
else if you say well we want to help
them we want to make their world better
we want to make their world more open
and connected we want to help them sell
stuff so we're starting to define these
values right like we want to persuade
people to be more open and connected but
what I want to talk about today is where
our ideas about making the world better
meet the rubber meets the road with
reality and what it would mean to
actually make the world better with
persuasion so I want to tell you a
little story
about kind of how I got into this and
got concerned when I was a kid I was a
magician and I basically studied from a
very early age that this instrument that
you're seeing me through right now your
conscious experience it can be
manipulated there's limits to our
attention there are limits to what we
can see and not see it as limits to how
we can think about something if I split
this room in half and said is the number
of countries in Africa greater than 50
or less than 50 and I asked you that and
I asked the other group as the number of
countries in Africa greater than 150 or
less than 150 just by anchoring these
two groups on different numbers you
would get different results and what you
start to realize as a magician is that
the human mind is living inside of a
24/7 magic trick you're basically inside
of an instrument that you can't see that
you're experiencing me right now and
that there's certain levers and strings
you can pull on to get people to think
about things in a certain way but I say
this because this was a childhood
interest and I didn't really do it for
that long I gave like one or two magic
shows but it gave me the kind of
foundations of that thinking and I want
to explain that I you know I later came
to Stanford I took the Mayfield Fellows
classes I got very interested in
entrepreneurship and I started a small
company called app sure which was about
learning and helping people learn things
on the Internet
and we thought what if we could apply
all that stuff I learned at the
persuasive technology lab for good let's
use it for good and oh I know what good
is because I'm a 23 year old you know
smart kid from Stanford so we built this
thing that basically let the Economist
would be one of our customers and you
would highlight something on the page
and we would persuade you to basically
go deeper and learn about something
we're just making we called it lighter
fluid for sparks of curiosity we thought
what could go wrong we have pure good
intentions we're just trying to help
people learn things were persuading them
to learn I'm used all these little
persuasive design techniques and as I
was building the company you know we
raised venture capital we had a team of
12 people as I was sitting there and
what got me waking up in the morning was
gosh you know I really want to help
people learn things that was about all I
could think about but at the end of the
everything that my company did was not
actually about helping people learn what
it really matter for the business was
whether or not we could tell the
economists that we were increasing how
much attention or time people were
spending on its website because
following so you know I had this goal of
hate on the web and we're gonna provide
this technology that's gonna make it
easy to learn about things but the way
we sold that to the publisher The
Economist was by saying we're gonna help
people spend more time in your website
and so I had 12 people that worked at
the company and I recruited them by
being really passionate by being you
know just classic like we're gonna
change the world we're gonna make people
learn about things gonna be great and
they really believed it I was very
persuasive as I was the CEO of the
company and I honestly as the founder of
the company couldn't admit that there
was a gap between my positive intentions
as a human being waking up wanting to do
this good and the ultimate thing that we
were measured by which was to capture
human attention and you know when you're
young and you're raising money and all
your friends are starting companies
there's this temptation to compare
yourself right you know they raise this
much money from dfj and I only raised it
from this other VC or you know they
recruited this you know brilliant guy
from LinkedIn and oh well we've
recruited these other people and there's
all these dynamics when you're running
something after you've built together a
team and you're basically out there in
the world with your company in your
product that how deeply will you be able
to examine your own motivations and
beliefs and see maybe what I'm doing
isn't about helping people learn at all
if that were true would I be willing to
see that that was true now think about
it if you've got you know we raised four
million dollars we had a team of 12
people their families their livelihoods
dependent on me I had a huge amount of
responsibility I was just trying to make
the business work and here I was
starting to question whether the entire
premise the values the core of what I
was doing every day were we actually
doing that
some friends of mine who were founders
of tech companies as well got together
one weekend and we got together because
we all talked about how there's all this
pressure that you face when you're an
entrepreneur this pressure to succeed in
to talk about how you're growing how
things are going better that you can
never express your doubts right everyone
sends home that says how's this going
you say oh well we just raised this much
money we just closed these ten more
customers it's going great
you can never just say like you know I
don't even know what I'm doing I'm not
sure that I know why I'm doing this
anymore
like where is it safe to utter that
sentence so my friends got together this
one weekend and we had a group called a
doubt Club and doubt club was basically
acknowledging that it's not safe
anywhere to talk with other founders
about your doubts about your company
your product on your life and we
basically went around the circle was
hyper confidential it's very safe we
basically said look the commitment here
is even above your connections and other
employees who might or might not work
for you or other investors are looking
at your company this comes first in a
small private group and we basically
shared our doubts about what we were
doing and it was in that moment that I
realized that there was a huge gap
between my positive intention that I
really wanted to do good but there was a
gap between this learning goal with our
company app sure and the actual
delivered thing that we had to do every
day which was capture human attention I
was able to see that and then I had to
figure out what am I gonna do so Tina's
told this story that makes it sound like
I'm some you know oh we sold this
company to Google and you know what a
successful entrepreneur but I'm gonna
tell you the real truth which is I was
terrified about what we were doing
I felt really lost about why I was doing
the thing I was doing and we had to
figure out what to do and we ended up
you know being in the situation we could
have raised more money but we were also
shopping the company around and seeing
you know what would happen and
ultimately we soft landed the company at
Google and so we had a nice out we had
two other two of the other people in
doubt Club ultimately one who got
acquired talent acquired for their
company we got talent acquired
and the other actually just shut down
his operation decided to move to Berlin
and do what he was like passionate about
but I say this because it's incredibly
incredibly hard to question what you're
doing Upton Sinclair the writer wrote
that you can't ask someone to question
the thing that their salary depends on
it's even harder to get someone to
question something that they deeply
believe is their purpose I thought the
thing about questioning someone's
religion or something like that or
questioning someone's identity and the
reason I'm talking about this is because
all of us in this room I imagine have
good intentions for where we want the
world to go and what it means to value
certain things that we care about but
we're only as good as the way that we
can self examine our own values so here
I was at Google and I was kind of
recovering as an entrepreneur I felt
honestly like I had failed I'd had I
needed to get psychotherapy I went to
Burning Man I had to kind of let go of
you know the life that I was living and
realizing there was more to life than
just starting companies right I still
had all these friends that it started
companies and then I was sitting at
Google and I was actually joined the
Gmail team and working on some future
looking personal assistants type
projects and I was working with Gmail
and I was in the room with the people
who make this product I was fascinated
at you know here's this Gmail product
that literally I don't know a billion
people actively use and you know that
hundreds of millions of knowledge
workers that that's the win it might be
open on some of your laptop screens
right now for all I know right we people
live in this product and it has this
extraordinary influence on the thoughts
that arrive in people's heads right like
just you're sitting there if an email
comes in right now it's gonna push
thoughts into your mind and you don't
get to choose whether that happens it
just it just happens and so I was
sitting this room you know thinking
about you know I really cared about
products that really delivered a
positive benefit in the world and I was
in the room with the people who would be
thinking the most deeply about what it
would mean to truly benefit people's
lives what email should do like one of
the values behind email like of all
rooms to be in in the world to be in
that design room is like that's the room
and I was I don't
disappointed but the way that the
conversations were had we're about let's
make it really fun to use let's make it
engaging what if we make it bounce up
when you scroll what if it expands
vertically instead of slides
horizontally and there was all these
design questions like that and I felt
that it was something missing I couldn't
put my finger on it for a while but I
realized later it's like when is email
actually adding up to a real net
positive difference in your life
think about the emails that you send
whether it's love letters or you
apartment searches we're actually
getting some real actual delivered life
change a real benefit a real value and
then think of all the other stuff that
we're just kind of shuffling messages
back and forth and I felt like of all
rooms to be asking this question we were
not asking the biggest question and
after a year at Google I was kind of
burnt out and I decided that I was
basically gonna leave at least I thought
I did and before I did I kind of took
these concerns and I made a presentation
and the presentation was basically never
before in history have 50 designers in
California at 3 tech companies
influenced what 2 billion people will
think and do right now and we have an
enormous responsibility as a company
that shapes this screen in terms of what
we are causing people to do and the
reason I was even thinking about that is
because I had this background as a
magician and in the persuasive
technology lab where I learned that
minds really are steered by forces that
they don't see so I have to say that in
making this presentation I actually
thought I was going to get fired
it was not alarmist or angry or upset
but it was very critical and it was very
existential like what does it mean for
actually email to be a benefit to
people's lives
and I was surprised because I sent it to
about 10 people and when I came into
work the next morning I got some e-mails
back and I clicked on their comments and
I went to the presentation in Google
presentations that showed the number of
simultaneous viewers was a hundred and
fifty and when I like clicked on it
later that day there was 450
viewers and basically I saw that it
spread virally around the entire company
when all the way up to Larry Page he was
in three different meetings that day
where people brought it to his attention
and suddenly I was in this moment where
I felt like you know the whole company
was woken up to this question of are we
actually influencing the world in a
positive way and that led me through the
next three years and actually an
executive at Google saw this and
basically generously offered to host me
in a little corner in his lab in New
York where I could study ethical design
which I basically self titled this role
of design ethicist and this new field of
what is ethical design or ethical
persuasion what does it mean to
ethically influence what two billion
people are going to be thinking and
doing and so that's basically what I did
for the next three years and I I went
really deep into understanding first of
all you know if you take the human
evolutionary code you know you're living
inside of a meat suit mind body right
that was tuned millions of years ago so
our predilection for sugar salt fat
we're tuned millions of years ago when
they were scarce but here we are now in
their abundant so we've got all these
tunings and you're living inside of it
and it can't really change you don't
really have a lot much optionality so
you're living inside of this thing and
if you made a map of every single string
you could pull on this mind/body system
to persuade it if you could make a map
of how could you a dict a human body or
a human mind how can you pull on its
sense of belonging how can you make it
feel like it's missing out how could you
get it to do certain behaviors how could
you get it to think about certain things
how could you get it to make certain
choices so if you had a map of every
single way that a human being could be
manipulated that was the first part of
the study the task second part of the
study was what would it you know what
would it mean to ethically persuade so
what what does it what's constituted and
ethically pushing this human animal
around in the world and then the last
question is values what are we pushing
it around for and who's to say how do we
know and we have values we can stand on
that we can actually persuade people in
an ethical way so I basically studied
this topic and I want to say that I
didn't know what I was doing
I was basically trying to figure out
this answer to this question of whether
we want to or not Google's gonna bump
its elbow and Apple's gonna bump its
elbow and face what's gonna bump its
elbow and a billion people are just
gonna go in these different directions
right because when you you know when you
wake up in the morning is important just
to set the context you know two billion
people that wake up in the morning and
the first thing they do is they like
check their phone and we checked 150
times a day you know in the bathroom
coffee line going to sleep like we spend
a lot of time in these devices and even
when we're not looking at the device the
thoughts that are in your mind right now
are still pausing you know partly set by
the time you did spend looking at the
device so we had this kind of 24/7
immersion in this environment and I
didn't know what I was doing in studying
this question I just found it to be
fascinating and important and
interesting and Here I am literally
whatever it is three days three years
later it's November 1st 2017 and the US
Congress is questioning Facebook Google
and Twitter about exactly the stuff that
I've been interested in for the last
three years and I honestly find myself
right now at the center of one of the
most important and invisible problems I
think in history which is that it's not
just that there's this system that's
kind of bumping its elbows into people's
psychology but we gave this system a set
of goals that are causing tremendous
harm so what do I mean by that the
reason I told you this story about why I
have these positive intentions and with
my company app sure we want to help
people learn and how there was this
doubt Club process to try and figure out
what that might have been you know what
we really would have been underneath
there and you know that I had to
actually examine the core beliefs that I
had is because I think that just like
everybody in the technology industry all
these companies that were up there today
in Congress have very positive
intentions for the world everybody at
Google and Facebook and Twitter that I
know really really cares about
delivering the best possible you know
world that we can we can create and yet
I would
that's something like the statement our
mission is to make the world more open
and connected is just the same as me
saying I want to help people learn about
stuff because what is that actually
about what it's actually about is
capturing human attention Mark
Zuckerberg actually faces this exact
same dilemma that I faced except he
raised a lot more money and his
company's in the public stock you know
stock market and one of the most
profitable companies in history and
controls what 2 billion people would
think every day but how could someone
like Mark Zuckerberg question whether or
not everything that they do every day is
actually about making the world more
open and connected if you think it's
hard as a founder when you're comparing
yourself to your friends and whether or
not you hire the good people you raise
money from some impressive people talk
about what it would be like to run one
of the most powerful corporations in
history influencing what 2 billion
people in every language think and
believe the terms of people's social
relationships and to actually question
whether or not the thing that you think
you're doing because you know you're
good you know that you're trying to do
good but how that might be different
than the actual result and the first
thing you have to do is pay attention to
incentives and I think this is really
important as an entrepreneur cuz all of
us I'm something many of you are gonna
go off in the world and start companies
is pay attention to who is paying who
what is the actual thing that you're
beholden to with my company it was the
economists they were our customer and we
had to do one thing for them which was
keep people on their website for longer
let's look at Facebook their business
model is advertising no matter what good
they want to do in the world their stock
price is dependent on how much attention
they capture youtubes Google's stock
price part of YouTube is dependent on
keeping people's attention Twitter's
stock price is dependent on keeping
people's attention everything else they
say is an intention that's outside of
that it's a dream this is something that
they'd like to have happen but the end
of the day the thing that they're
beholden to is capturing human attention
and I want to talk about why this
situation I'm gonna take you down a
little journey which might leave some of
you more alarmed than you intended to be
but I promise that all I'll turn it
around at the end I want to scare you
for a moment about where we are because
I think that we're in a much more
dangerous situation than people tend to
recognize the goal of capturing human
attention becomes this arms race for
who's better at being a better magician
and pulling on the strings of human mind
right so you have these products
competing and everyone's trying to
figure out how can I get more attention
and then my friend Mike Krieger at
Instagram says hey just like with
Twitter let's add the number of
followers that you have to our product
if we add the number of followers we
have then everybody has to log in every
day to see how many they have and they
want to get more so they have to come
back to the product every day so this
one tiny design choice right these
products just it just evolved like an
organism that evolved this new hand and
that hand is really adaptive for the
adaptive environment which is what's
good at capturing attention we just
invented this new persuasive thing but
what could the consequences of that be
and how would you as an engineer
designer be thinking about that you
might say well we're helping the world
because now people know like who's
following them and now people know that
they can connect with certain people
that are interested in they're
interesting you can see the list of who
follows you and there's all sorts of
benefits positive things that could come
from that and when you're a human being
living inside of the eyes and mind and
beliefs of of someone who makes
Instagram or Twitter you're thinking
about it in terms of those positive
things because that's what you're trying
to do but how would you know that might
cause a whole bunch of other
externalities because right now the
number of people who define their
self-worth based on the number of
followers they have David Brooks wrote a
book called the road to character and he
talks about the world value survey and
how people in value different things
over time and one of the big things
that's changed is that people went from
valuing Fame and
18 in the list two valuing Fame as
number one analyst so in that's in the
last sorry that's been the last like I
think ten years or something like that
and I would argue that the reason that
like literally billions of people now
value fame higher on the list is
actually because of little tiny
seemingly innocuous things like putting
the number of followers that you have in
the core of our software interfaces
right so we have this natural situation
where everyone's competing for attention
and we are evolving these systems to get
better and better extracting human
attention and we then it gets really
competitive and we have to add something
else so what do we add we add AI so now
instead of just offering a product to
you I actually have to predict with big
amounts of data and machine intelligence
what's going to keep you on the screen
instead of just offering some stuff you
can click on I'm gonna actually predict
from millions of things I could show you
if I'm YouTube what's the videos I can
put in front of you if I'm tinder I'm
gonna pick from millions of people I
could show you what's the perfect reason
to not be with the person that you're
with if I'm Facebook I could say all the
million things I could show you in the
news today what's the perfect thing it's
gonna get you to like click or share
okay
so you have an AI that's basically been
given this goal now I want you to put
this in context when we think about AI
we have to remember you know when when
you point the AI system at chess right
first it kind of Wiggles around and it
makes some kind of funny-looking moves
and then starts making the smart moves
is it gets better and then it makes them
surprisingly smart moves and then it
beats Garry Kasparov and when a beats
Garry Kasparov it doesn't unbe Terry
Kasparov it's now better than all human
beings at chess right so you take that
same AI and you point it at the go game
and that took 30 years that made these
funny-looking moves and now with alphago
with google's alphago it beat all of go
players and when it beats all of go
players it doesn't unbe all of go
players
so we built these AIS and then we
actually invisibly gave it a new target
we pointed it at this and we said
whatever gets this human being play
chess against this human beings mind and
and play twenty steps ahead of where
their mind could even possibly see and
show stuff to them that is either that
perfect next video on YouTube the
perfect outrageous news story on
Facebook which controls what two billion
people will think every day the perfect
reason for you to cheat on your spouse
with tinder the perfect political
message so we can very 60,000 political
messages and we can actually combine
word choices and different contortions
of politicians faces and colors of
buttons to perfectly animate a response
from your brain stem because we're
playing chess against ourselves and we
have every clique that we give this
system it gets stronger right every time
you click or you share you're feeding it
attention which feeds it more dollars is
feeds more resources which feeds it more
computing power which means it's better
at playing chess on your mind
the reason this should be alarming is
that these systems are not neutral we
have a tendency to say you know we've
always had computers smart I mean
computers video games radio TV we always
worry about them so why should we so
concerned this time and there's a few
different reasons that this is so
different and the biggest one is this AI
enhancement that I just mentioned a
couple others are that no other medium
could pull on your social psychology so
no other medium could show you an
infinite set of reasons of why other
people are living better lives than you
are an infinite set of reasons for why
you should feel like you're missing out
other people are having fun without you
an infinite set of reasons why you Opie
police Ponce's you didn't open your TV
and it said you know what you owe like
100 people responses you better start
getting back to them right
so we're doing such enormous I want to
say harm or damage but we're doing there
is so much that is now put on the human
evolutionary animal right more than
we've ever put and especially when you
add in AI so now the question becomes
what's what is the goal of that AI what
does it actually once so if this is not
a neutral product of this is not just
sitting here but it actually wants
something from me well if you're Mark
Zuckerberg you think the thing you
program the AI to do is to make the
world more open and connected which you
translate into let's engage people let's
show people whatever engages them and
that's going to be very persuasive to
someone who's living inside of that mind
but we have this problem because the
actual thing that this is all based on
is attention it's the same contradiction
that I felt and we now have this system
that's you know we always talk I don't
know how much you talk about it here at
Stanford but there's all of this
discussion about runaway AI what if in
the future we were to build a runaway AI
like a paperclip Maximizer and we give
it this goal to make paperclips and it
turns the whole world inside out just to
create paperclips and what if that would
happen it how would we make sure that
wouldn't happen so there's all these
people working on AI safety and the
amazing thing is that this basically
already happened because we already
built a runaway AI that's tearing what 2
billion people's thoughts are and we hid
it from society by calling it something
else we played a magic trick on the
human mind because if you call it a news
feed or you call it
YouTube's recommended videos or you call
it
tinder recommendations people won't even
notice that's how easy it is to fool the
human mind so
let's see what do I want to go what
we're really dealing with is we have
systems that have exponential impact
right Facebook just disclosed in the
hearings today and yesterday that there
are more than five million advertisers
on Facebook okay and that means that
there are also potentially hundreds or
thousands or millions of campaigns per
advertiser so you get this combinatoric
explosion and so if you have China or
North Korea or Russia or someone else
who's trying to spread manipulative
advertising not even for a politician
but just for divisive issues or
conspiracy theories or lies the problems
we've created an exponential system of
persuasion without exponential guidance
or exponential ethics to control it to
govern it and so where we find ourselves
is basically the situation that many of
the people who are worried about runaway
AI haven't been talking about forever
and that's the situation where we're at
and I don't mean to depress you but
that's that's actually where we are like
right now like today and the Congress is
just now waking up to basically the
reality of what this system has the
power to do and the cats out of the bag
now you could say well hold on a sec and
we talked about these future scenarios
where if you have runaway AI there's
always this discussion of like well
let's put it inside of an air-gapped
computer and it won't like get out right
or we can always pull the plug let's
just shut the thing down we can always
pull the plug I think it's not gonna be
a big problem because we can always just
turn the computer off if we have this
runaway AI in the future but the problem
is if you think about what that would be
today that would basically be like
turning the lights off at Facebook now
it's not as if from an existentialism
perspective as a human being you can't
like get out of your chair and walk out
of the room and space in time and tell
the board of directors you know we're
gonna shut this thing off you could
physically do that but there'd be
consequences and we can't turn off this
system that we've created so the only
way to solve a system that's runaway
pursuing its own goals is not to manage
your relationship to it I'm saying this
because I want to contextualize a lot of
people think of if you've read any of
the work that I've done that it's about
we got to better manage our relationship
to our phones let's be more mindful with
our phones that's like saying when chess
is kicking your butt
you know let's manage our relationship
to the chest that's just totally
overpowering where we are so the only
way to solve this problem is actually
put the AI on the same side of the table
as us we have to be really honest about
what the lines of power are so right now
the thing is pointed at us
it's extractive it basically says I need
to extract as much attention out of you
as possible and the classic line is it's
a race to the bottom of the brainstem so
it's not enough that I offer you the
product I have to reach deeper down into
the brainstem and create an unconscious
habit so now you actually pull for the
phone more often that's not enough I
have to reach even deeper down to the
brainstem and on your social psychology
so the way that snapchat basically owns
people's social relationships that's not
enough I have to reach deeper down to
the brainstem and get to your self
self-worth and control your sense of how
often people like your self-worth so I
told you I'd go dark I apologize so we
have this extractive economy if you'll
notice it doesn't look that different
from how the broader economy is
structured when it's extractive it's the
same as the environment we have a
runaway system that makes more money the
more you extract without putting
something back in balance so the
fundamental situation here is we need to
find a more ergonomic relationship with
the boundaries of our architecture in
the case of how it's extracting us and
if you don't care about us let's talk
about our kids because this thing is
just eating kids alive for breakfast so
we can do that but I think that what
this is about is just like the point
where we were where we realized you know
after we extracted coal and we created
this incredible economic prosperity
after generating energy with coal but we
also polluted the external environment
and no one really saw that at the time
good intention people created this bad
stuff and we just realized it later and
we're at that point we're just realizing
the extractive attention economy where
we're capturing people's attention he's
basically polluting the external
environment it's also cluding the inner
environment and now we need to invent
solar and green basically solutions like
things that are regenerative or economic
or replenishing to the human being so
you can make all the same metaphors of
the environment right and that's gonna
mean that things don't grow the same way
one of the reasons why advertising is
such a great business model is because
it grows you know incredibly fast and is
super profitable I mean who wants
Facebook to be regulated when the stock
price is like through the roof right now
but also who wants the changes that
we're going to need to make for climate
change to take for climate change to be
abated
given that we're gonna have to make huge
sacrifices and so the conversation
actually comes back to values it comes
back to mi willing to value something
else besides money am I willing to value
something else besides status now this
is an open question when it comes to
corporations who basically they don't
have control or choice we created these
robots called corporations that are just
maximizing profit and they have to
there's no like way they can't do that
so we have to acknowledge when that
misalignment exists and it's the same
for our own lives you know just because
I can start a company and my friends
you know I've friends personally who've
you know sold a company for a billion
dollars now that's very seductive we can
be pulled it's a magic trick we can be
pulled by basically other people's
success or incredible amounts of money
right but the comp the conversation
always comes back
- what do we care about what is this for
what is the problem that this technology
is the solution to why am I doing this
and if we ask those questions that's
really the essence of ethics you know I
have this fancy title of having been in
the former Google design ethicist I will
tell you I didn't study that much
philosophy at Stanford I think the
deepest ethical question you can ask is
simply asking questions and asking why
and so with that I will open it up for
some questions thank you and really
important are there examples of
companies that are doing this well yeah
are there examples of companies that are
doing this well you know I think that
yeah all right we can get into the
theory of change there is a whole bunch
of companies whose business models are
aligned with us anyone you're paying
right the the money is going directly
you're paying the person that's serving
you so you know we actually on time
well-spent website we have a bunch of
different products that we basically
show you you pay for the for the product
and they basically help you calendly
helps you schedule meetings efficiently
basically name any product that you pay
it delivers value and you pay like on a
monthly basis so anything like like that
I don't want to give I mean I'm for some
reason these these examples are sort of
fleeting my mind but there's all sorts
of products that are that are like that
I think the main thing we have to do is
recognize that the advertising
supporting products are the ones whose
incentive is to extract from you and
it's always hard to acknowledge that
because we get also benefits from
advertising we get the fact that you
know we enjoy getting an ad for Nike
shoes that we really wanted to buy but
the problem isn't the ad it's the
misalignment of incentives so yeah and
what if we paid for Facebook for example
but question the back
see your a magic trick in itself
and is the first part where you present
something ordinary it's humble CEO a
start-up in total Valley and then you
have a turn which is and here's what's
behind curtains and without club and
your journey of you know discovering the
extraordinary on top of the ordinary but
then the third and most difficult part
of any magic trick is the prestige it's
how you get it back how do you come how
do you bring this extraordinary Ness
into the ordinary and so and your magic
trick was about your journey and your
insight and and about how the this
journey allows you to create kind of
magic through design or to whatever you
did you're doing but my question is is
it the purpose of this to create people
that believe in magic
what is it to create more magicians
because what I don't understand is that
we're spending all this time trying to
create the perfect system the perfect
Gmail the perfect platform which is in
itself a magic trick so that people can
continue using it so that people believe
in its magic adequacy but my question is
why don't we spend more time creating
magicians and decentralizing design or
allowing people to design their own
experience different content was I think
I think their take I appreciate your
question I think you're taking the magic
metaphor further than I was intending
yeah it's not it's not about the magic
of ethics or values or these kinds of
things I think the point of the magic
frame is that it exposes the fact that
we're inside of a system that can be
pulled or drawn it's more delicate or
vulnerable or manipulable than any of us
would like to admit and right now all of
our design institutions and our metrics
don't account for that model human
nature they're governed by simpler ideas
like we're giving people what they want
or if you clicked it that's what you
wanted which is very
places when you tell someone that but
then you could imagine if you said well
are there any cases where someone clicks
something and it's not what they want
but they were outraged they were you
know upset they were you know that kind
of thing
another question all right student yeah
instance if you were to tell one of them
to just remove like how to persuade a
company to remove one of these
time-consuming features without them
jeopardizing their competitiveness to
remove snapchat streets yeah you know
yes so the question is really in the
attention economy where everyone doesn't
even matter if you're building you know
snapchat or you're building a meditation
app even meditation apps need your
attention you have to figure out how to
put a habit inside of your body so that
you use it every day how do you tell any
company not to get people's attention or
to subtract some of these manipulative
features from their products is your
question so the answer is you cannot
obviously get any person whose business
model is to maximize how much attention
they get from you to not do that you
can't tell YouTube to not try to show
people the next videos you can't get
snapchat to now subtract the streaks
feature so the way to do it is you have
to go up a level and you go up a level
by going to the device and the platform
so in other words we can't actually ask
Facebook do something Anson's business
model but you can ask Apple Microsoft or
Amazon or Samsung who are companies
whose business models set up the choice
architecture which is the interface
between you and this army of things that
wants your attention and so right now
that choice architecture because we have
this model of human nature that says
people are clicking or choosing freely
is this wild-west right like basically
when you get a phone it's like Apple and
Google give totally open door access of
all those apps to just reach into you
and do all the stuff that they want to
do so there's a bunch of ways they can
clean up and mediate that relationship
so it's like if we're jacking people
into the matrix do we want to jack their
impulses or do we want to Jack basically
the top part of the reflective minds and
there's ways of designing the choice
architecture on a phone like a home
screen or notification
that are basically asking the most
reflective part of ourselves what we
want and to make that concrete that's
the theory the concrete version are
things like conversational interfaces so
Siri the air pods watches things that
have supplemental interactions that are
peripheral interactions in which you
basically are doing something with the
device for you're not giving people a
bottomless bowl of things to scroll
through and explore in an infinite world
which is what they're all based on now
so that's that's one period of change as
the platforms and the other one is
governments we can talk about that more
later yeah so that that sounds like
you're talking about further up the
chain I'm just wondering on the other
side it can you dint chain I guess I'm
wondering if you're seeing culturally an
acceptance that this is a real problem
you know is it widespread or is this
just a small group that feels this way
yes so is it important for driving
change so is there a large group of
people who agree or see the problem and
is that important for driving change
I'll say a couple things on that one is
I felt so nervous making that first
presentation at Google like I thought
that's like yeah I can't be I honestly
thought if there's someone else if this
problem existed someone else would have
thought of this and said it already and
and I felt really nervous putting the
idea out there because I was basically
saying humans don't choose freely here's
all these ways that we don't and I felt
uncomfortable saying that I felt very
vulnerable and it actually it's been
this process over for years of being
repeatedly validated that people
understand that you really this really
does happen this really does work this
way that I've felt more comfortable
stepping into it and I'll say since then
the acceptance from more and more X and
alumni of the big companies have come
out at least privately to me in
agreement and so basically I was on 60
minutes earlier this year with Anderson
Cooper talking about this problem we
call it brain hacking and it was mostly
the addiction part of this problem and
since that interview Mark Zuckerberg is
personal mentor Roger McNamee who
actually convinced mark not to sell the
company to a Yahoo or Microsoft for a
billion dollars and now feels incredibly
conflicted about his role in creating
Facebook has actually partnered up with
me and we've been doing all this great
work together and there's been more and
more people who've been coming out of
the woodwork because they understand
this is a
the situation we're in is so I would
actually say if you don't see the
situation this way and it's resembled
who doesn't and they're in the industry
and they actually work on these products
it what's happening is more of the up to
the Sinclair can it get people to
question the thing that they're doing
thing and we always want to look for the
positive yeah yes the question was is it
true that is it true that executives in
their schools to places where they don't
have phones there's limits the answer is
yes and I think that's always a really
telling signal is when the CEOs of
companies don't feed their own kids with
whatever it is that they're making it's
an extension of the golden rule it's
like you know don't just do unto others
what you they would do to you do unto
others what you would do to your own
children and I you know I know Steve
Jobs limited his phone his kids phone
and tablet access
I think Sheryl Sandberg doesn't let her
kids use social media as I understand it
I know there's people at Apple that are
very high up that send their kids to
Montessori schools and I think the
Google is very similar and I'll just say
you know in parallel when the the CEO of
Lunchables food liners a billion-dollar
food product would not let his own
children eat lunch apples and you know
that there's a problem when that's when
that's true so like what do you
so what should we as consumers do if we
don't want our minds to be pulled out
the first thing to recognize and this
took me a long time to kind of get
across is I interviewed all sorts of
people who had like the best experts in
the field on persuasion and behavioral
economics and magicians and you know I
had lunch with them years ago when I
started working on this with Danny
Kahneman who was actually one of the
founders of the field of behavioral
economics he's the Nobel Prize winner in
Himmel economics which is how we can
kind of fool people and in his book
Thinking Fast and Slow he says look even
though I know how all these techniques
work and then be how these cognitive
biases work it still works on me now the
important part to realize that it's like
okay if you told someone I'm gonna give
you access to know what your DNA looks
like then you don't think well then now
I can change my hair color from red to
something else right so I think the
challenge is that we really are inside
of this experience we're really inside
of cognitive biases if I do that Africa
a number of countries thing and I anchor
you on one number versus another number
whether you want to or not there's all
of these invisible influences that are
guiding us and so the question becomes
what how do you epically use those those
forces and then again for good and for
what for what values in terms of being
concrete what do you do you can turn off
all notifications on your phone except
for when a person wants your attention
so one of the big things in the industry
is just about everything that's a
notification that comes at you is
actually generated by a machine and the
machines goal is usually like what will
get your attention right now and so it's
automated lis sending you stuff if you
ever even you tried the following you
don't use Facebook for like a week
and then you watch suddenly they send
you like 3,000 emails it's like a drug
dealer who wants you to come back so I'm
not trying to be I hope when I say this
I don't sound like I'm just trying to be
against something I'd say it's more that
there's this model that's just not
aligned with all of us right I don't
think anyone wants a world where this is
going that's hopefully when I
communicated it's like this is so
dangerous where we're headed I want to
say one more thing about what danger
that I didn't mention
I think the deepest existential risk
from this is that the thing that's best
at capturing a human beings attention a
single person's attention is going to be
show them an individual reality that
confirmed
their World News that's gonna be so
different from the thing that would
confirm our shared sense of reality so
you can think of Facebook and knock you
like they gave it this innocuous naive
goal of like let's help people let's
engage people the most and then that
thing is taking entire societies and
putting them through a paper shredder
we're out the other end you get
basically filter bubbles and echo
chambers when people don't have shared
facts and agree on the same reality
that's like I think the deepest part of
the problem so if you weren't convinced
by the kids threat or the national
security side I think that is a sort of
step one for good Society okay so the
question was if you take a persuasive
technique what how would you apply an
ethical framework for deploying it okay
so let's take I love this example so
let's take streaks and snapchat sorry if
you've heard me talk about this but it's
really important because if you didn't
know snapchats the number how many of
the students here you snapchat is your
primary okay so good number okay so and
it's obviously invented by Stanford alum
who has good intentions but they use
this feature which is a technique
because it's persuasive design technique
called streaks if you are older in the
audience it shows the number of days in
a row that you've sent a message back
and forth with every contact so why is
that is that ethical or not I want
actually here what do you think if I put
the number of streaks in a row there
were days in a row that two kids upset a
message back and forth
what makes that is that wrong is that
good is it bad what okay so if it
increases your quality of life and helps
you feel more connected with your
friends then that would be one reason
why we say it's good so let me tell you
actually what the people at snapchat
when they made this feature what I've
heard through the grapevine is the way
they they justify this was that unlike
these other social apps that connect you
to all of these friends all at once you
have like all your relationships all
ones they help you focus on the
relationships that really matter because
they show you the depth of your
friendships
do you see you I'm talking about you
again you have a belief in a narrative
in your walk you're stepping inside of
this belief where everything you see
through these rose-colored glasses where
this is deepening friendships according
to the human being that believes those
thoughts they're inside of a magic trick
and they believe that this is actually
about deepening friendships and there's
definitely evidence for that I'm sure
that there's someone somewhere two kids
who feel like mad my friendship is way
deeper because I can see the number of
days in a row I've sent a message back
and forth there's somewhere in his
experience that just like there's magic
moments on all these other applications
but there's still something that's not
quite right about it and I'll just jump
to the chase with snap shrieks there's
first of all in asymmetric situation so
the children don't know that there's
like a thousand and/or hundred engineers
on the other side of the screen and that
they're deliberately choosing this
technique against them so that's one
thing so there's an asymmetry between
the knowledge that the persuaders have
and the knowledge the persuade D has
okay second one is that the just had it
the goals of the persuader are different
than the goals the persuade D so when
the people who make snapchat do this
their actual goal is how can i hook you
to use the product every day because
that works really well like the streaks
feature is super addictive that's their
goal and the goal of the person who's
using it usually the challenge of
ethical persuasion is people don't know
their own goals so they actually just
sit there and then the persuaders goal
infects the persuade D so now the
persuade D is like a like the matrix
they've been there's a drilled hole in
the back and there's goal when it and if
like now I need to keep up with these
streaks and now they actually want that
that's something that they intuitively
independently want that's successful
advertising the persuaders goal has
become the persuade ease goal and now
they define their friendship based on
whether or not they're able to keep up
their streaks and if they don't have
their streak they're no longer best
friends and by the way that's actually
true
so there are children walking around who
think that they're you know they're that
they're terms of their friendship are
there streaks that they have but I want
to just do one more thing here but it's
a great example so have you asked me
that is the you could do the same thing
a streak feature on a meditation app
same feature now we're putting on a
meditation app the number of days in a
row you've meditated so why is it
feeling it like intuitively it feels
better there right
so why is that and I'll just say quickly
it's because I theoretically the person
who's trying to meditate actually cares
their goal is aligned with the
persuaders goal they actually want to
sort of mark off the number of days in a
row that they've done the thing that
they're yearning for whereas in in the
first case that's not true so this is a
whole well this is the challenge of
advertising is they make money whether
or not you buy it or not because they
still make money from just the
impressions for seating the ideas into
your mind that's still a success case
for advertisers and I know that we're
rapping no please but that the challenge
here is there are other metrics my first
TED talk I went through some of them the
challenge is that any business model any
business or company technology company
whose business is to capture attention
they just have to do that like there's
just no other choice YouTube just has to
do that but if you look at Vimeo it's a
counterexample they don't autoplay the
next video they don't show you the
related videos and try to get you into
an infinite world and it's because their
business model is a little bit different
and so you can imagine a version where
you pay where these choice architectures
are not trying to bottomless boil you
into infinite
so yeah Wow I'm sure you'd all agree
this was incredibly important and
provocative please join me and thank you
Trista
[Applause]
you